today on the mat wall show it's election
day and it looks very different from any
other election day in modern american
history shops are boarded up
the national guard guard is on standby
and none of this is being done to
protect against possible mobs of angry
republicans we know that
also five headlines including a cnn
contributor sincerely arguing that
donald trump is
literally worse than hitler and i think
this is a if donald trump wins it's
gonna be in big part because of
nonsense like this from media also
reports of families being ripped apart
by political differences
is there ever a good reason to disown a
family member because of the politician
they support
and finally in our daily cancellation
maybe not the issue that's on the
forefront of people's minds right now
but i will cancel daylight savings time
once and for all it needs to be done and
it will be done today but we start here
you know as america heads to the polls
today as i mentioned it here's a
question that i've been pondering maybe
you can help me out
because i i can't really remember back
in 2008 and 2012
did any businesses have to board up
their windows for fear that republicans
would riot
and loot if obama won and when obama did
win both times if you recall
did republicans then ride and loot did
they see what i remember is the tea
party movement which rose to prominence
in obama's first term and i remember
thousands of tea party rallies across
the country and i remember not
one single example anywhere at any time
of any form of writing or looting at all
by anyone
that's what i remember and yet now in
2020 the scene in many cities
as we get ready for polls to close is
truly dystopian
it's the kind of thing that would have
been unthinkable up until recently the
kind of thing that you saw in other
countries
and judged them for it and felt superior
and thought
well that doesn't happen here we're too
civilized we don't do that here
but it does happen here now thanks
exclusively to the left and the
democrats
exclusively to them businesses across
the country are boarding up the national
guard is being called in preparations
are being made for violence and chaos
because of a presidential election
here's a report out of
new york by the new york the new york
post it says new york city restaurants
are getting ready in case election day
comes served with a site of civil unrest
as retail shops from the gucci boutique
in soho to the macy's flagship on herald
square board up their storefronts in
case of riots
restaurants across manhattan say they
aren't fooling around either
patsy's italian these 75 year old uh
neapolitan eatery will be closed on
election day for security reasons
and sal namillo the restaurant's
third generation chef slash owner um
says that
they boarded up the eatery on monday and
also beefed up security hiring two
ex-nypd
uh armed guards for election day and
wednesday when he plans to reopen
however he says he will be monitoring
the climate to see how it goes
we hope to reopen for dinner on
wednesday but we'll play it by ear
in the case of restaurants the new york
police department has warned that
outdoor tables and chairs
that lately have become ubiquitous on
sidewalks could be weaponized by riled
up crowds
the advisory was addressed to manhattan
eateries south of 59th street
but there are many other restaurants
across the city that are
taking similar precautions and then in
chicago you can see here images of the
national guard
rolling into town a report by cbs and
austin
talks about all the business owners
boarding up in that city it starts like
this it says
on the eve of election day some austin
businesses were busy boarding up their
storefronts in anticipation of the
election day
unrest these are scary times especially
for my employees
said jagat patel patel's the owner of a
7-eleven on congress avenue he says
cruz began boarding up his business with
wood and plexiglas on sunday
he says it's something i thought i would
never have to do
and then meanwhile in dc it's especially
depressing
with whole city blocks under lockdown
here's nigel
farage in um in dc yesterday
with the video camera going around
surveying the scene and here's what he
found
so this is connecticut avenue um it's
the road up we're not more than much
from sort of half a mile away
from the white house and can you see
what's happening here in dc
the place is being boarded up
uh one or two businesses have not yet
been boarded up but they will be by the
end of the day
and this is right throughout the city
and this is in anticipation of real
violence
following the result or even an
inconclusive result of the election on
tuesday so it's eight o'clock in the
morning
as you can see a few protesters are
beginning to gather um i wouldn't dare
show my face down here later in the day
i can tell you
um and let's just get let's just be
straight about this
why they boarding up dc what are they
scared of are they scared
of trump supporters are they scared of
some of these slightly crazy groups
out in america no what they fear
is that trump wins and that we get you
know from little groups like this
large-scale violence looting and writing
and then you see here even more images
out of dc from a bbc correspondent
i have to say it's especially
embarrassing to have these international
reporters and correspondents and things
reporting on this because
like i said we're not supposed to be
like this in america we we don't riot
over elections
we have peaceful transfers of power or
peaceful retentions of power as the case
may be
but that era seems to be over or most
people think it's
over at least our confidence
in having peaceful elections is gone and
for good reason
you know um but but why is it why do
these
business owners uh think that they have
to put plywood over their storefronts
are they worried about rampaging
republicans are they concerned about
thousands of
q anon devotees descending on their
cities
no they're worried about leftists
they're worried about democrats
they are worried about the reaction from
the left should donald trump win
nobody is concerned about the reaction
to a biden win
except for the possibility of
celebratory rioting which may well
happen
but nobody thinks that republicans will
take to the streets
and start stealing consumer electronics
from department stores
in response to abide in win that won't
happen i'll say it right here
and i'll eat my words if i'm wrong i'll
say it will not happen period
and we all know it won't happen here's
the truth and
this is not a simplification it's the
reality
not all leftists are rioters and looters
but
all rioters and looters are leftists
this is exclusively a phenomenon on the
left it is exclusively a tool
a weapon of the left and if you want to
talk about rigged elections
the main rigging happening in this
election is is
is the implied threat of violence should
donald trump win i have no idea how many
people in cities
in cities and business owners especially
will vote for biden simply because
they're afraid of what will happen
to them in their livelihood if trump
wins and the mob becomes enraged
but i'm fairly sure that there are a not
insignificant number of people
who are at least tempted to vote against
their political beliefs and interests
purely out of fear of the mob and i can
understand that inclination
but also it's exactly why you can't vote
democrat
putting everything else aside if
democrats
win the mob wins a democrat victory is a
victory for
mob rule mob justice yes the mob will
have its tantrum if it doesn't get its
way the rioting and looting
is disturbing and sad and if you're in
the middle of it it's terrifying
but the much more disturbing sad and
terrifying prospect is that these people
should get their way
should seize power should have more than
umbrellas and
glass bottles to use as weapons against
their political enemies
that's the terrifying thing the mob
cannot win it must not win
it's gotten its way far too often
whether it's the violent mobs in the
street allowed to destroy whatever it
wants
or the cancel culture mob on social
media bending people to its will
extracting
phony apologies through threat and
blackmail the mob in both forms
is first of all always on the left
and second of all always wrong always
evil
must always be opposed denied rejected
whatever the mob wants we should always
do the opposite
when you've got a mob of people
threatening violence if you don't do xyz
that in and of itself is a very good
reason to do abc
and i hope that's the result today but
and i pray for that result but we'll
find out soon enough
in the meantime let's get to five
[Music]
headlines
well as we talk about voting there's
another kind of uh sort of voting
you can do and that's with your wallet
to support
companies that support you and it's
really important to support companies
that have your back in the culture
uh that that believe the same things you
do and stand for the same value as you
do
and i can tell you one company that
definitely falls
in that category and that's the pro-life
phone company charity mobile
charity mobile is a great great company
great service and five percent of your
monthly plan
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice so you can decide
what charity you want some of that to go
to and that's where it will go
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with three
activations and free shipping
and look there's no contracts there's no
termination fee
so they're not going to try to you know
stop you from terminating by by by
leveling some sort of fee
and there's no risk with a 30-day
guarantee but at the same time i think
if if you use charity mobile like i do
you're going to find that none of that
matters because you're not going to want
to leave anyway it's such a great
company
there's live customer service based in
the usa and you've also got the ability
to you know protect your kids and your
family
by blocking use of cellular data picture
messages text messages
you can have those parental locks if you
need them a lot of other
a lot of other perks as well free usage
alerts free free app to monitor your
usage
pay your bill many other things i know i
use that with my charity mobile phone
and here's what comes out you can help
to build a culture of life in america
and you can turn
everyday living into effortless giving
to the charity of your choice and it
really is that simple so
call charity mobile at
online at 1-877-474-3662 all right well
all eyes are on pennsylvania today which
makes this tweet from the attorney
general of pennsylvania all the more
disturbing
he tweeted this on monday afternoon
hours before the call the polls even
would
would would close of course or had even
opened
in fact um this is what he said if all
the votes are added up in pennsylvania
trump is going to lose that's why he's
working overtime to subtract as many
votes as possible from this process for
the record he's 0-6 against us in court
we've protected voting rights now ignore
the noise and vote
okay the second part of that whatever
um he's telling people to vote fine but
the first part of it is is it just me or
is this guy indicating that he knows the
results of the election
before it's actually been decided
he said he he declared it trump's going
to lose
so this would seem either to be an
attempt to suppress republican votes
all this the complaints about voter
suppression on the left this seems like
voter suppression
suppressing republican votes by telling
people that there's no point biden's
already won
or alternatively um it could be
something more sinister perhaps criminal
i mean
if he really does know the results of
the election before it happens
then we've got a problem and if he
doesn't know then we're back at
uh at voter suppression number two
the cnn contributor and supposed expert
on mental health
uh tweeted this she might know something
about mental health problems from
experience i guess she says donald trump
is not an
adolf hitler at least hitler improved
the daily life of his followers
had discipline and required more of
himself to gain the respect of his
followers
even with the same pathology there are
varying degrees of competence
okay so donald trump is literally worse
than hitler he's just like hitler
except less competent and less
disciplined that's the take from this
person who's on cnn all the time i think
she's on msnbc also a lot no surprise
there
where do we even start here do we need
to address the claim that the guy who
tried to literally invade the world
was disciplined um
do we have to break this down
historically and address that
he had the respect of his followers i
yeah when you when you when you require
respect or you get sent off to a death
camp
um yeah that's pretty easy to extract
respect though it's not really respect
that's just people
um in fear because they're living under
tyranny but
probably it's not necessary to analyze
this historically
um i think i'll just leave it at this if
trump wins today
it'll have a whole lot to do with stuff
like this i think people see these kinds
of attacks from the media
and then rightly dismiss everything else
they hear
from the media also there are a lot of
people who see the hysterical and
despicable media
and vote trump just to spite them i've
heard from a lot of people like that
now that's not the majority of trump's
support if you look at the rallies
people are obviously excited about trump
you know in in a positive sense actually
like trump himself
but if this is a close election uh i
i don't think it'll be an exaggeration
to say that
this sort of stuff in the media is what
probably put trump over the top
people voting just to spite them number
three bernie sanders was
speaking with the squad recently and uh
he said the quiet part out loud
as they say or maybe he just said the
out loud part out loud because i think
they've been pretty
upfront uh and direct about this but
here's what he had to say
so our first test we made it clear
everybody's no great secret
our first task we've got to defeat the
worst president in the modern history
of this country and number two we
organize our people
to make sure that biden becomes the most
progressive president since fdr
yeah i'm not sure uh first of all what
that was exactly
does does the squad have a podcast or
something do they get together for
karaoke
so i'm not sure what the context was of
that but either way bernie says to the
squad
we've got to make sure biden is the most
progressive president we've got to make
sure of that
which is another way of saying this
dude's brain
is made of soggy cheerios at this point
and we're going to
use that to our full advantage that's
what they're just announcing
now biden even if he had his wits about
him
certainly could not be trusted to stand
up to the radical left because he lacks
the willpower he lacks the courage and
integrity
he's just a mediocre man uh a a career
politician
almost all career politicians by
necessity are
exemplars of mediocrity but considering
he is half senile
on his way to being full senile he
couldn't resist them even if he wanted
to
and that's a part of this whole picture
um that somehow hasn't been discussed
and emphasized enough
it's been discussed and emphasized a lot
but i i still think
not quite enough because perhaps the the
the only argument that should have ever
been necessary to make against joe biden
is this i mean there are many other
arguments you can make
but why why should we need to go further
than just saying
he's 78 years old and he's losing his
mind
that's it i mean really nothing else
even matters
78 years old he's losing his mind we
we can't put this guy in charge of the
country give him the nuclear codes we
can't do that
maybe we will do that i don't know
but all of the crises that follow
will have been totally foreseeable and
preventable in that case because
in that case we'll be taking a guy who's
78 years old
he's in the process of losing his mind
everybody knows it
we make a joke about it but it's also
100 percent true
and uh we're putting him in the white
house the most stressful job
when even if biden were to just go home
like he should be
just go home sit on his porch in a
rocking chair and uh
whittle away the final years of his life
even if he did that
um the chances are astronomically high
that in the next four years he's going
to be full senile just when
you look at the trajectory but then you
put him in the most stressful job in the
world
there's really no chance of any other
outcome so what happens
what happens when we have a senile
president
i mean are we gonna know about it are
they gonna be honest with us and tell us
what happens next what do we do about
that
i don't think anyone knows exactly
because this is gonna be um
this is going to be untreaded territory
but we might find out hopefully we don't
but we might number four there have been
a lot of stories in the media about how
the election is tearing families apart
so here's one from reuters that says
when lifelong democrat myra gomez
told her 21 year old son five months ago
that she was voting for donald trump at
tuesday's presidential election
he cut her out of his life she says
quote he specifically told me
you are no longer my mother because
you're voting for trump
um their last conversation was so bitter
that she's not sure they can reconcile
even if trump loses his re-election bid
the damage is done in people's minds
trump is a monster it's sad
there are people not talking to me
anymore and i'm not sure that will
change
said gomez gomez is
not alone in thinking that bitter splits
within families and among friends over
trump's tumultuous presidency
will be difficult if not impossible to
repair even after he leaves office
whenever that is
in interviews with 10 voters five trump
supporters five uh
biden supporters a few could see the
wrecked personal relationships caused by
trump's tenure fully healing and most
believe them destroyed forever
throughout his nearly four-year norm
smashing presidency
trump has stirred strong emotions among
both supporters and opponents
many of his backers admire his moves to
overhaul immigration blah blah okay we
don't need to read that part
okay so the um of course reuters is
blaming trump for this
so which is stupid but i think there are
two points here
number one political differences in a
family
can make for great arguments and debates
over thanksgiving
which are always fun but if you're
disowning family members over them
you're not only a bad person you're also
very stupid and boring
um i don't understand people who take
political disagreements personally
at all but especially in a family in my
family you know
we we basically agree on the fundamental
issues but we still find plenty to
debate and argue about
and we have these knock-down drag out
debates over all kinds of things and
it's a lot of fun nobody gets their
feelings hurt at least i don't get my
feelings hurt
i don't think anyone else does and we're
fine just imagine being a grown man
and running away crying saying that you
never want to talk to your mother again
because she disagrees with you
politically
my god i i can't wrap my head around
that
i cannot even contemplate having a
political debate with my mother
and getting so emotional that i run away
screaming i never want to see you again
get away from me i can't imagine
reacting that way to anything
least of all a political debate and even
less
a political debate with my family so
learn to embrace these arguments and
differences it keeps things interesting
imagine if you if you were in a family
and everyone agreed about everything
and there was nothing to discuss or
debate i i can't imagine living in a
family like that
number two another point though um that
i always think about when i read stories
like this
which is um uh why are you talking to
the media about your family drama in the
first place
so i'm sorry for miss mrs gomez that uh
her son is treating her this way but
what a a reporter from reuters calls you
up
and says hey um i was wondering if you
wanted to air your dirty laundry about
your family in front of the entire world
i'm doing a story do you want to tell
the entire world about the strife
in your family in your home do you want
to oh you do great
that's another thing i can't imagine uh
so
those those are the two tips to take
away if you have debates in your family
that's good it's a good thing it keeps
things fresh and interesting
but if you do have serious strife and
drama
maybe keep it out of the media keep it
off of social media too we have an
epidemic of over
sharing in this country must much of it
happening on social media but also
through
traditional media as well nobody needs
to know
no one needs to know if you hate your
mother or if you're having problems with
your son
uh no one needs to know that
okay number five let's see
yeah i think we're on fire right okay
finally as we wait for the polls to
close
i've looked at a lot of the early voting
numbers and the exit polls myself
and i wanted to show you a few maps that
i drew up
just based on how i ran the numbers i
thought this would be interesting to do
and i haven't really given my
predictions but i wanted to do that now
so so first of all this to me is the
most plausible scenario and i'm going to
say right now this is my official 2020
prediction
and you can look at the map here i've
got kanye west
winning 286 electoral votes and becoming
our next president
as you can see there kanye takes
california texas florida
biden takes pa trump does pull out a
victory in minnesota
this i would say is the most likely
scenario and i think we can all agree
that that
if it does happen it'd be pretty great
let me show you let me let me show you
my nightmare scenario and i can't rule
this out
here's the map right here
as you can see the whole country has
turned into an emoji um
this again for me is the nightmare
montana and minnesota are the eyes
south dakota is the nose then you got
the mouth there smiley face
horrifying um but a possible outcome
and i'm a little worried about this also
uh this is kind of a horse as you can
see washington is the head
idaho's the main that could be a horse
or a giraffe i don't know
but this is a concern so we just don't
know how it's going to end up at this
point um or what the picture
what picture the country will ultimately
draw but we'll know soon hopefully
and this is the kind of analysis
that you get from this show everyone
else is doing serious election
analysis and predictions and i'm over
here like look mommy i drew a horsey
that's that's me that's that's the kind
of political pundit i am what else did
you expect
really if you're looking for intelligent
political analysis i don't know why you
came to me in the first place
speaking of intelligent political
analysis i can tell you where you can
get it
the presidential election is uh
happening now and um
our live stream starts today at 3 pm
eastern 12 p.m pacific featuring special
guests
live interviews and more leading up to
our evening show where we'll be covering
the results with you in real time
and even better you can join daily wire
now get 25 off with code election so you
can watch
all of our election coverage live on our
apple tv roku app members get our
articles ad free access to our live
broadcast you get three hours of ben
shapiro show
you all these um all of these
uh perks as well as you can if you
become an all-access member you get to
join our all-access live every night
with one of our hosts where we have a
discussion
and you also get not one but two leftist
tiers tumblers so lots and lots of perks
there
if you want to watch the election again
dailywire.com get 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today
all right let's get to our daily
cancellation now for our daily
cancellation today
i know this isn't the issue that is most
important to people right now
but it's important nonetheless that's
why today i'm canceling daylight savings
see what happens every time we fall back
as we did
on sunday is that i have to listen to a
bunch of people
talk about how great it is to get an
extra hour of sleep but i always know
that those people are not
the parents of young children because
any parent of a young child knows
that kids don't follow daylight savings
they don't care what the clock says
so you push the clock back all that
means is that now we're waking up an
hour before the crack of dawn instead of
waking up at the crack of dawn like
normal
my kids have been waking up at 4
30 4 30
ever since daylight savings ended
admittedly our situation is compounded
by the fact that we moved to tennessee
and
what when it went back an hour then we
moved back another hour from daily
savings so
my kids biological clock is still two
hours in advance of what the clock says
which makes it harder when i have to
listen to all these privileged
well-rested people go
oh man so great to get an extra hour of
sleep
refreshing really is it great is it
refreshing
that's good tell me more about that tell
me more about how great it is
i haven't slept since i i have not slept
past 6 30 in
seven years so tell me more about waking
up at 9 00 a.m i'd love to hear it
i'm so happy for you and we're being put
through this
for no reason daylight savings is
totally arbitrary and pointless
i remember in school they told us that
you know we do daylight savings
for the farmers right but this is just
one of the many random things they lie
about in school for no reason
it actually has nothing at all to do
with farmers why would it
how would it help farmers for us to
randomly move our clocks
forward and then back they have to be up
early to milk the cows regardless
cows aren't going to adjust their
schedule any more than my kids will
neither will cr neither will their crops
so this was not done for farmers
do you know why it was actually done i
bet you didn't know this
it was done so that a new zealand bug
collector
could have more time to collect bugs
that's true
i think that's what i read on wikipedia
anyway five seconds ago
a guy named george hudson in 1895
decided that that he wanted more time
after work to look at beetles or
whatever so
he proposed that we move the clocks
forward
and pretend that it's later than it
really is and everybody was like
okay sounds good and we all agreed to
just
pretend that time had shifted so that
this freak could play with his bugs
now i may be condensing things a little
bit daylight savings wasn't actually
adopted nationwide in our country until
1960 1966
with the uniform time act when the
president signed a law
simply declaring that the time will move
for forth and then back or that we all
must pretend that it moved
think about how crazy that is it's like
a law that says that we all have to
speak in pig latin on tuesdays or wear
yellow pants and
hop up and down for 14 seconds every
third day but it's worse than that
because we're trying to move time itself
we're trying to manipulate
actual dimensions of reality and not
even in a cool or interesting way i mean
if we're gonna do this
why don't we all decide that march
doesn't exist
just wipe march off the calendar that
way we get to the summer faster
we could pass along call it the march
erasure act of 2021 and from henceforth
there's no march if you had a birthday
in march you no longer exist
legally so you will be killed we could
talk about that part of it but but but
you get the idea or hear something
better let's turn thursday into friday
friday into saturday and then we can
give ourselves two sundays
thereby creating a four-day weekend or
we could get rid of time
days months and years completely and
instead you know your age will be judged
based on the number of
pigeons you've seen in your life so a
person who lives in the city might be
6 000 pigeons old while someone in a
pigeonless era might be
area might be three or even zero you
know we
we could do this we could move time
forward and back we can do this too
or the alternative we could just let the
time be the time
let the clocks run stop playing god stop
tormenting parents with young children
and live our lives with clocks that
operate consistently not arbitrarily
this is something to think about as you
vote today or i guess not because no
candidate has
made it an issue sadly maybe next cycle
but um i i believe there
there is there is just no good argument
anymore for daily sales
the only argument for daily savings is
it's just that it's what we do that's
the only argument if you ever talk about
this
with someone and someone defends
daylight savings their entire argument
is just yeah but you know this is just
what we do now
okay well let's stop doing it the bug
collector
has tormented us for over a hundred
years
let us free ourselves from this maniac
once and for all
that is uh my final message to you on
this election day
and remember again to tune in um very
soon dailywire.com
as we're gonna have election coverage it
might get a little bumpy
tonight and into tomorrow but we'll see
pray for our country godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
astrologers predict a win for biden
cookies predict a win for trump
and the pennsylvania attorney general
gives the state to joe before election
day
check it out on the michael knowles show